bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat en cette rentrée
scolaire je vous propose une matinée
consacrée à la thématique de l'éducation
avec tout d'abord et bien les questions
cribles consacré à la réforme du collège
une réforme contestée qui aura lieu à
partir de la rentrée 2016 la ministre de
l'éducation nationale najat vallaud
belkacem l'a encore réaffirmé cette
semaine
cette réforme je vous le rappelle
prévoit la mise en place d' enseignement
pratique interdisciplinaire
enseignements qu'ils croiseront les
compétences tissus de différentes
disciplines dans le cadre d'un projet à
thème
la réforme prévoit également
l'apprentissage d'une seconde langue à
partir de la 5ème problème est bien cela
signifie à la fin la suppression des
classes bilan qui permettent à certains
élèves d'apprendre deux langues dès la
6e également les détracteurs de la
réforme bien fustige la fin du grec et
du latin en tant qu'options tout de
suite donc retour à ces questions
cribles c'était au mois de mai vous
allez le voir à l'époque les sénateurs
avaient pu expliquer exprimé certaines
de leurs inquiétudes
même si nous nous inquiétons du court
délai entre la publication du décret et
sa mise en oeuvre à la rentrée 2016
les membres durs groupe rdse et moi même
tenons à réaffirmer notre soutien au
collège unique
cet outil met au service d'une ambition
démocratiques fortes assurées au plus
grand nombre de jeunes
le maximum de chance comme le prônait
jean zay ministre de l'éducation du
front populaire en 1936 est entré hier
au panthéon le collège unique parachevé
par la loi haby chers collègues en 1975
a permis d'ouvrir les portes de la
connaissance à toute une classe d'âge
qui jusqu'àlors en était privée est
entré prématurément dans le monde du
travail
les dispositions de votre réforme
propose de dégager davantage de temps
trois heures en sixième une à deux
heures les autres années pour un
accompagnement personnalisé
et pouf et vous en définir le cadre plus
précisément l'instauration d'
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
insuffle un renouveau pédagogique c'est
bien mais pensez vous qu'une année
scolaire suffira pour adapter d'urgence
l'organisation de la formation continue
avant la rentrée 2016 nous tenons aussi
à vous interroger sur la place des
enseignements disciplinaires
fondamentaux au sein de cette réforme au
premier rang desquels doit figurer le
français constatant une diminution du
volume du volume horaire accordée au
français en sixième est convaincu avec
les membres du groupe r d est ce que la
réussite scolaire dépend de la maîtrise
de la langue française tant orale
qu'écrite puisqu'elle rend possible
l'apprentissage des connaissances des
savoir-faire des nouveaux moyens de
communication et d'information sans
oublier la formation de l'esprit
critique
quels moyens entendez-vous déployés afin
d'en faire la pierre angulaire de la
réforme du collège en augmentant les
horaires en 6e plutôt qu en les
diminuant
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est à mme vallaud belkacem liste
de l'éducation nationale avait la parole
de la ministre monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice françoise laborde la
réforme du collège a un objectif très
simple en effet faire mieux apprendre
chaque élève pour les faire tous mieux
réussir et vous avez eu raison de le
dire et nous partageons évidemment votre
ambition il nous faut affirmer ici que
la réussite
la réussite scolaire doit être offerte à
chaque enfant en particulier lorsqu'on
parle d'enfants de moins de 15 ans et
qu'un bagage commun doit être donnée à
tous ces enfants de moins de 15 ans qui
fréquente le collège que nous voulons
unique nous réaffirmons cette ambition
mais que nous ne voulons plus uniforme
c'est à dire qu'il doit mieux s'adapter
aux difficultés ou parfois aux avances
de chacun des collégiens qu'il reçoit et
c'est pour cela que la réforme a prévu
d'innover dans les pratiques
pédagogiques d'un produire davantage
d'accompagnement personnalisé
de travail en petits groupes et de créer
ces fameux enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire sur lesquelles je
reviendrai pour répondre aux trois
questions que vous me posez
l'accompagnement personnalisé
il aura vocation à la fois à expliciter
aux élèves ce qu'on attend d'eux les
méthodes pour apprendre la façon dont on
révise ses leçons dont on prend ces
notes dont on s'organise pour réussir au
collège vous savez que il ya un vrai
changement entre l'école primaire et le
collège notamment en classe de 6ème
c'est pour ça que de l'accompagnement
personnalisé il y en aura trois heures
par semaine pour chaque collégien
il sera évidemment fondée sur les
programmes d'enseignement cet
accompagnement personnalisé il ne s'agit
pas d'apprendre autre chose aux élèves
pendant ces trois heures
d'accompagnement que ce qu'il y a dans
les programmes
il permettra à ceux qui sont en
difficulté de rattraper ce retard à ceux
qui sont en avance d'approfondir leurs
connaissances
donc il ne porte en rien préjudice à
ceux qui pourraient être les meilleurs
au contraire il les rendra excellent les
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire je les dis c'est une
façon à la fois de faire travailler des
enseignants en équipe avec du coup
renseignements plusieurs enseignants de
disciplines différentes de faire
travailler les enfants en groupe parce
que ce sera sous forme de projets
concrets pratiques qui permettent comme
le disent les anglais de faire du
learning by doing c'est-à-dire pas
simplement des apprentissages théoriques
mais la mise en pratique de ce qu'on
apprend dans les disciplines
fondamentales
non le français ni perdre rien comme
aucune d'ailleurs des disciplines en
l'occurrence le français qui aujourd'hui
bénéficient de 17h30 de la 6e à la 3e
bénéficiera toujours de définir coupure
de la 6e à la 3e
un dernier exemple si vous prenez un
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
comme celui qui s'appelle éducation
artistique et culturelle lorsque vous
allez faire jouer à des enfants d'une
classe une pièce de théâtre c'est
évidemment pour renforcer aussi
l'acquisition du français que vous le
ferez voilà en quoi ce sera utile aux
fondamentaux madame laborde briller
bon je serai très brève monsieur le
président parce qu'il y aurait plein
question mais comme je suis la première
je sais que d'autres en poseront juste
une dernière requête pratiques que vous
noterez pour pouvoir nous répondre
ultérieurement
pouvez vous nous indiquer quelle
incidence aura votre réforme sur le
brevet des collèges
merci la parole de notre collègue aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologie
avaient la parole mes chers collègues
mais c'est le président madame la
ministre la réforme des collèges
applique les choix du parlement qui se
sont exprimés dans la loi refondations
de l'école face au constat inacceptable
d'une école qui aggrave les inégalités
et aux choix coupable d'avoir supprimé
la formation des enseignants le collège
va désormais davantage concilier
personnel mieux préparés exigences pour
tous et attention à chacun dans les
territoires où la crise sociale frappe
particulièrement durement des équipes
travaillent déjà depuis des années avec
des résultats remarquables les
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire vont accroître leur
coopération à condition que les équipes
bénéficie pour cela de temps et de
formation cependant la réussite de tous
a besoin de mixité la population
scolaire d'où ma première question
madame la ministre
comment la réforme du collège sera
t-elle accompagné par une politique
volontariste en matière de mixité
sociale des élèves
par ailleurs cela ne peut se faire sans
les enseignants toujours dans cet esprit
de reconstruction d'une école plus juste
je souhaite que la plus grande vigilance
soit apportée aux remplacements
effectifs des enseignants absents des
créations de postes sont annoncées par
exemple en cette année où ils seraient
au nombre de cinq cents pour les trois
ans qui viennent c'est un effort mais il
est insuffisant il en faudrait trois
fois plus pour que la permanence de
l'encadrement de la continuité des cours
soit assurée la situation aujourd'hui
sur certains territoires n'est pas
acceptable quelle décision comptez-vous
prendre un sujet enfin pour que l'école
soit un lieu d'épanouissement pour tous
les élèves
il nous sommes qu'il faut qu'elle soit
un lieu bienveillant madame la ministre
au-delà de cette réforme ne pensez-vous
pas nécessaire de transformer en
profondeur les méthodes pédagogiques
d'un pays d'encourager l'innovation
davantage afin d'assurer la réussite de
tous les enfants et d'encourager aussi
comme le font des pays comme la finlande
depuis des années
la coopération et non la concurrence
entre les élèves valoriser toutes les
formes d'intelligence et non pas
seulement un modèle unique qui en
lestant de côté je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondra par l'autorité
de la ministre
merci madame la sénatrice archimbaud
pour cette question qui me permet en
effet de revenir sur ce sujet de la
mixité sociale
la mixité sociale nous la développons
oula favoriseront lorsque nous aurons et
c'est toute l'ambition de la réforme du
collège réussi à offrir dans chaque
collège de france
un niveau d'exigence un niveau de
qualité d'enseignement qui soit le même
partout et qui veillent pour chaque
enfant quelle que soit sa situation de
départ quel que soit l'état dans lequel
sept enfants arrivent en classe de 6ème
qu'il est acquis les fondamentaux qui
était attendu de lui ou pas à le faire
progresser
je crois que ce que craignent
aujourd'hui beaucoup de parents qui
refusent de mettre leurs enfants dans
tel ou tel établissement de secteur
c'est le fait que les difficultés de
quelques autres élèves au sein de ces
établissements ne soient tellement pas
bien traités qu'ils ont peur que leurs
enfants soient tirés vers le bas c'est
ça la difficulté du collège actuel et
c'est ce contre quoi nous luttons
lorsque nous disons que partout nous
voulons avoir une exigence des
programmes qui renforce l'acquisition
des fondamentaux
une évaluation qui va évoluer en effet
j'en profite pour répondre sur la
question du brevet car tout est lié
et oui le nouveau brevet en 2016
veillera à venir évalué cette capacité
non seulement à l'écrit mais aussi à
l'oral cette capacité à travailler en
groupe ces nouvelles compétences que
l'on développe dans le nouveau collège
mais pour en revenir à votre question la
première façon de favoriser la mixité
sociale c'est de veiller à ce que chaque
établissement offre le meilleur c'est ce
que nous faisons notamment en innovant
sur les pratiques pédagogiques la
deuxième façon de garantir la mixité
sociale c'est de retravailler c'est ce
que nous faisons avec des conseils
généraux des conseils départementaux
pardon pour revoir la sectorisation
avoir des secteurs plus large dans
lesquels il y ait plusieurs collèges
pour avoir davantage
de pouvoir d'agir en terme d'affectation
des élèves et veiller à ce que tout en
restant dans le secteur de son domicile
eh bien les élèves puissent être
répartie de façon plus équilibrée c'est
un travail qui ne peut pas se faire du
haut vers le bas en imposant à tout le
monde a même modèle qui doit être très
pragmatique et c'est pourquoi je
vraiment je voudrais souligner la
qualité du travail que nous effectuons
avec des conseils départementaux de
gauche comme de droite qui ont accepté
de se saisir en ce jour j et puis enfin
je terminerai par la situation du
département de la seine-saint-denis
puisque vous l'avez évoqué oui
évidemment la création des postes
et puis notre capacité à avoir des
candidats sur ces postes importe on a
déjà créé 330 postes en seine saint
denis vous savez qu'on va encore en
créer 500 conclut le regret c'est un
travail qui est à poursuivre évidemment
madame archambault brièvement s'il vous
plaît merci madame la ministre
j'entends ce que vous dites notamment
sur les efforts qui sont qui seront
faits pour revoir les questions de
sectorisation je pense qu'il ya en effet
là un travail un peu faim à faire
évidemment évidemment en coopération
avec la police locale
concernant ma troisième question sur sur
l'innovation
l'innovation est le fait aussi de
d'avoir sans doute de d'introduire sans
doute ou de renforcer de nouvelles
méthodes pédagogiques alors j'ai bien
compris que ma question était se situer
au delà de la réforme des collèges mais
je crois que c'est une question
importante notamment que les que les
pratiques les valeurs de coopération
entre les élèves soient beaucoup plus
encouragé qu'elles ne sont aujourd'hui
je crois aussi certains pays le font que
ce serait une façon de permettre à
certains élèves de s'épanouir davantage
de même que je crois que certaines
formes d'intelligence sont encore
aujourd'hui peu valorisées pour ne pas
dire plus
j'ai pas le temps développé mais aura
peut-être le faire une autre fois je
vous remercie bien la parole est
maintenant aux madame brigitte gonthier
maurin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen je rappelle chacun à
tenir bien les deux minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre lors de notre question
d'actualité la semaine dernière
vous avez affirmé poursuivre l'objectif
que les élèves assimilent mieux les
différentes matières qu'ils ne sortent
pas sans les avoir comprise raisons
motivant son heureux découpage entre
enseignements disciplinaires obligatoire
et enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire vous indiquer que les
horaires des enseignements
disciplinaires ne baisse pas pourtant on
passe bien 200 8h30 d'enseignements
communs à 104 heures sur tout le collège
et encore je comptabilise pas les
horaires des enseignements facultatifs
ce choix ne peut répondre à la
nécessaire élévation du niveau des
connaissances indispensables regarde
l'évolution des savoirs car comment
imaginer bâtir des deux pays avec un
socle disciplinaire affaibli vous
présenter ces deux pays comme une clé de
la réussite de tous mais comment ne pas
voir que leur contenu sera variable d'un
établissement à l'autre au détriment de
discipline aussi fondamental que les
sciences la technologie ou les
enseignements artistiques qui enseignera
quoi n'est ce pas mettre le doigt dans
le développement de la bivalence voire
de la trivalle ans les 4000 postes
annoncées pour accompagner cette réforme
en découdre est il autre élément
indispensable à 100 de votre réforme
la formation continue des enseignants
elle est en déshérence nous ne sommes
pas les seuls à nous en inquiéter j'en
veux pour preuve le référé d'avril de la
cour des comptes
ce chantier est au point mort hors les
enseignants français sont les plus mal
lotis de la côte catégorie a de la
fonction publique avec seulement trois
jours annuel de formation continue alors
que les pays de l' ocde en octroie 8 en
moyenne
ma question vous et que vous évoquez une
mise en route à l'automne prochain
pouvez vous me donner dès lors à
calendrier précis le contenu et les
moyens attribués en détaillant les
crédits de fonctionnement et les tp je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre vous avez
la parole pour deux minutes
monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice gonthier-maurin
d'abord pour répondre à votre question
dans la prenant par la fin oui
indéniablement pour que cette réforme du
collège entre en vigueur dans les
meilleures conditions nous avons besoin
de former et d'accompagner les
enseignants c'est bien ce qui est prévu
et je veux vous rassurer de ce point de
vue nous avons quinze mois devant nous
pour le faire c'est ce sur quoi nous
travaillons d'ores et déjà et nous
invitons les organisations syndicales à
le faire avec nous pour adopter les
textes d'application de cette réforme
qui préciseront notamment le nombre de
journées exact de formation dont
bénéficiera chaque enseignant qui sera
amené à mettre en oeuvre ce texte
c'est vrai que il y à de nouvelles
pratiques
une nouvelle culture même à adopter
parce que nous introduisons 20 %
d'autonomie pour les établissements
parce que nous ignorons dans la pratique
pédagogique pour autant je veux vous
rassurer
rien de tout cela ne fragilise l'idée
d'un cadre national et d'un collège
unique bien au contraire d'abord parce
que la liberté que nous laissons aux
établissements et aux enseignants elle
est tout de même encadrée par des
horaires nationaux chaque collège
respectera exactement les mêmes horaires
par des programmes qui sont les mêmes
par une évaluation évoqué tout à l'heure
le prouver et puis que s'agissant des
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire auquel vous faisiez
allusion il d'abord il ne s'agit pas de
partir dans le vague sens des
limitations puisqu'ils y a bien 8ème
nationaux qui ont été définis on pourra
revenir sur leurs détails et que ces
8èmes surtout d'enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire s'appuie sur les
programmes
c'est en cela que je disais tout à
l'heure qu'il ne porte en rien préjudice
il ne laisse en rien les disciplines
fondamentales
au contraire chaque enseignante de ces
disciplines est amené à adapter une
partie de sa pratique pédagogique pour
faire faire ce que votre collègue évoqué
tout à l'heure notamment davantage de
travail en coopération aux élèves pour
sortir d'un schéma parfois un peu
théorique un peu magistral qui rend les
élèves
siph là où nous voulons les rendre
créatif et acteur voilà ce que j'ai pu
lire merci mais non mais non tu m'aurais
dit merci madame
la minus pour ses réponses non je veux
dire nous sommes en attente de réponses
concrètes identifiant et détaillants
concrètement les moyens qui vont être
alloués à la formation continue parce
que depuis lé 2010 en fait c'est moyen
sont en stagnation et de plus on sait
que la prise en charge des frais
relatifs à la formation la transporte
les les repas ne cesse de baisser et je
ne suis pas sûr d'ailleurs je crois que
la cour des comptes le point que les
espèces est totalement anticipée et
intégrée
cette question en tout cas la cour des
comptes non plus ne le pense pas donc
j'attire votre attention
et puis dernier élément si j'ai le temps
en 10 en 2009 il ya eu un rapport de
l'igpn consacré à l'enseignement intégré
des sciences et technologies qui a été
et qui a évalué dans cette
expérimentation pédagogique
la conclusion c'est un succès mais la
deuxième la deuxième phase de cette
conclusion c'est que ce n'avait pas
vocation à être généralisée compte tenu
de la complexité de le faire et
notamment du besoin de volontariat des
équipes enseignantes donc voilages
j'attire vrai monsieur je prêche
vraiment pour la tension suivi tout
particulier
merci ma chère collègue la parole est
maintenant aux dames la présidente
françoise cartron pour le groupe social
il avait la parole d'un président merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
au travers de cette réforme du collège
vous poursuivez aujourd'hui l'ambitieuse
refondation de l'école initié par
vincent peillon 2012 cette loi de
refondation que j'ai eu l'honneur de
rapporter ici et qui a d'ailleurs été
largement débattue et largement amendé
dans certains mystiques
tout d'abord respectant nos engagements
la priorité a été accordée à l'école
primaire
auparavant grande oubliée des politiques
éducatives et pourtant socle essentiel
pour la réussite des élèves
désormais le temps est venu de procéder
à la réforme du collège moment critique
de la scolarité pour un certain nombre
d'enfants fragile début avril le conseil
supérieur de l'éducation à dos
un avis positif à cette réforme du
collège et vous venez d'en publier les
décrets nécessaires à la mise en place
effective ceux ci deux ans après le vote
de la loi dont pas de vitesse ni de
précipitation mais une ferme volonté
d'avancer les associations de parents
d'élèves que notre commission recevait
hier anne audition soutiennent la
réforme car celle ci répond au besoin
d'identifier des enfants ils nous ont
dit ce n'est pas de plus d'heures
d'enseignement dont ils ont besoin c'est
de mieux d'enseignement mais le succès
ne sera au rendez-vous qu'à condition
que les enseignants s'approprient ces
changements et pour cela il est
nécessaire qu'ils bénéficient d'une
formation et d'un accompagnement
suffisant notamment dans la mise en
place des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire alors aujourd'hui
maderna ministre ma question est la
suivante alors que nous sommes désormais
entrés dans la deuxième étape c'est à
dire la mise en oeuvre pratique de la
réforme
quel calendrier est aujourd'hui prévue
afin de répondre aux inquiétudes
exprimées
quelles modalités de discussions avec la
communauté éducative dans les semaines
et les mois à venir
mes chers collègues le temps n'est plus
à la polémique mais au travail de
construction permettant de réussir
ensemble cette école pour tous les
enfants de france pour vous répondre la
parole à madame l'oms pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice cartron merci pour votre
question qui me donne l'occasion je vous
remercierai tout autant
qui me donne l'occasion de préciser une
chose il a toujours été clair pour moi
qu'il fallait distinguer et ne surtout
pas faire de confusion entre l'hostilité
absolue et par principe à la réforme et
les interrogations que peuvent poser un
certain nombre d' équipes enseignantes
qui sont des interrogations
professionnels et auquel il nous faut
apporter des réponses et c'est bien pour
cela que je dis que évidemment nous
souhaitons les avoir leurs organisations
représentatives autour de la table pour
construire ensemble les textes
d'application de cette réforme
je veux répondre à certaines de ces
interrogations d'abord en rappelant que
cette réforme du collège ne se fait pas
à moyens constants
nous créons 4000 postes c'est ce qui
nous sera bien utile pour notamment
développer les petits groupes de travail
dont je disais les vertus tout à l'heure
ça se traduira concrètement pour chaque
collège par une augmentation de ce qu'on
appelle sa dotation horaire globale qui
lui permettra d'avoir davantage de marge
de manoeuvre pour renforcer ici ou là en
fonction de ce que l'établissement c'est
ça la marge d'autonomie aura décidé
comme prioritaires pour ces élèves
compte tenu leurs besoins c'est ça la
grande nouveauté de cette réforme c'est
de permettre à l'établissement
considérant que les élèves ont du retard
particulièrement en france et ou d'untel
ou en langues vivantes et c'est de
mettre le paquet sur ces matières donc
ça c'est la première chose les moyens la
deuxième chose c'est l'accompagnement et
la formation donc concrètement c'est cet
automne et c'est pour cela que c'est
important de préparer tout ce qu'il faut
tout le cas de repos c'est cet automne
que seront formés à la fois les cadres
c'est à dire les chefs d'établissements
les inspecteurs mais aussi les
enseignants qui le seront s'agissant des
enseignants sur site ce qui signifie
concrètement que des équipes de
formateurs se déplaceront auprès d'eux
dans l'établissement plutôt que de les
sortir pour pouvoir les former ensemble
eux qui seront invités est amené à
travailler précisément ensemble de
machault conclure donc voilà les
quelques indications que je peux vous
donner
mais vous savez
madame la sénatrice aucune réforme
n'entre en vigueur on ne se met en
application dans de bonnes conditions
si nous n'accompagnons pas les
principaux acteurs les enseignants et
donc je leur roddick bien évidemment les
quinze mois qui viennent serviront à
cela à 24 ans brièvement pour permettre
à nos collègues
oui oui merci madame la ministre en tout
cas je pense que la formation est
nécessaire au sein des sp mais je crois
aussi qu'il faut mieux mobiliser tous
les corps d'encadrement et en
particulier les inspecteurs des
inspecteurs départementaux qui sont plus
près du terrain et qui pourront répondre
à l'inquiétude parfois légitimes des
enseignants mais en tout cas leur dire
qu'ils ne seront pas seuls et qu'ils
seront accompagnés
merci ma chère que l'aig la parole est
maintenant à madame la présidente
catherine morin desailly pour le groupe
union des démocrates et indépendants
union centriste avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
si le rapport annexé à la loi de
refondation de l'école mentionne la
nécessité de repenser le collège unique
jamais les modalités précises d'une
future réforme ont été évoqués lors des
débats au parlement ainsi des
préoccupations demeurent vives et
nombreuses parmi les élus mais aussi les
enseignants nous avons eu l'occasion de
visionner et hier et qui nous disent ne
pas avoir été concerté donc parmi ces
questions je voulais en pointer du doigt
une question fondamentale grandes
inconnues de la réforme qui est la
question de l'orientation
l'arrêté prévoit la suppression des
options de découverte professionnelle en
classe de 3e tandis que les classes
dites prépa-pro demeure mais sans
horaires attribués à ce jour le nouveau
parcours individuels d'information
d'orientation et de découverte du monde
économique et professionnelle qui
remplace le parcours de découverte des
métiers et de la formation ne bénéficie
lui non plus d'aucun horaires
spécifiques et devra donc être
organisées sur du temps disciplinaire
dès lors comment permettre aux élèves de
déterminer leur choix d'études et de
profession est ce là une volonté
délibérée de retarder le choix
d'orientation à la seconde est de
limiter l'orientation vers les études
professionnelles
enfin le gouvernement est déjà passé en
force sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
cette fois on nous explique que le délai
d'ici à la rentrée 2007
mais de réfléchir au contenu des
formations les enseignants soit mais je
n'ai entendu personne se préoccuper d'un
autre aspect très concret de la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme à savoir la
rédaction et l'achat des nouvelles des
nouveaux manuels scolaires
je ne vois pas comment les collectivités
vont pouvoir faire face à cette dépense
inédite par son ampleur alors qu'elles
subissent déjà tout le contrecoup de la
baisse des dotations de l'état hors
toutes les disciplines mes chers
collègues dans toutes les classes du
primaire et du collège sont concernés
d'où ma question comment les
collectivités ont elles été associés à
la mise en oeuvre de la réforme est un
financement spécifique par l'état madame
la ministre de cette dépense est il
prévu pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame la ministre
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice morin desailly d'abord d'une
certaine façon on pourrait presque nous
reprocher d'avoir attendu trop
longuement avant d'adopter le ce décret
ce décret qui est tout de même la
résultante d'une loi la loi de
refondation de l'école qui a été
définitivement adoptée au parlement il y
à 22 mois 22 mois plus tard nous
adoptons ce décret alors vous dites que
il n'en a pas été question dans cette
voie de refondation je vous invite à
relire les échanges d'une certaine façon
je regrette si à l'époque vous n'aviez
pas eu l'occasion de poser les questions
qui vous viennent aujourd'hui je suis
prête à y répondre mais il y a eu cinq
mois de débats parlementaires cinq mois
de débats parlementaires la loi de
fondation de l'école d'ailleurs pour
répondre à certains d'entre vous qui
nous demandent pourquoi on ne se
préoccuperait pas d'abord de l'école
primaire avant le collège la loi être
fondation de l'école a précisément prévu
de prendre de façon chronologique tous
les sujets qui se posent à notre système
éducatif nous avons commencé par l'école
primaire laquelle nous avons donné la
priorité notamment avec le plus de
maîtres queux de classe où la
préscolarisation des enfants avant trois
ans et maintenant vient le temps du
collège et c'est ainsi qu'il faut
procéder notamment pour permettre à tous
les enfants d'acquérir ce fameux socle
commun de connaissances compétences et
culture dont vous avez décidé dans la
loi de refondation et qui doit se
décliner
avec à la fois des programmes qu'ils
soient repensées pour mettre les
fondamentaux en leur coeur c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure et aussi un
fonctionnement par cycle de trois ans au
cours de la scolarité qui permet de
mieux s'assurer du fait que les enfants
maîtrisent ces connaissances
j'en viens à votre questionnement sur la
façon dont les élèves pourront être
mieux informés en matière d'orientation
professionnelle
je peux vous dire que c'est un enjeu qui
est absolument fondamentale pour moi et
c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que dans le
nouveau collège l'un des enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaire parmi les
huit que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
s'appelle précisément monde économique
et professionnelle c'est à dire que ce
sera l'occasion pour les enfants de voir
dès la classe de 5e en l'occurrence des
sujets que jusqu'à présent ils n'aborder
qu'à la fin de la troisième comme
comment construire 100 dans son
orientation découvrir des métiers
découvrir l'apprentissage dont tout le
monde se gargarise mais à un moment
donné si on veut changer notre culture à
l'égard de l'apprentissage du fou
peut-être le valoriser tôt dans la
scolarité au collège c'est ce que nous
ferons dans cet enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire qui conduira par
exemple les élèves à l'aide de leurs
professeurs à construire des
mini-entreprises à permettre à
l'établissement au mode d'anvers
l'environnement économique a passé des
partenariats avec les entreprises qui
l'entourent voilà non mais je voudrais
juste répondre en détail parce que je
crois que le nouveau collège en effet
veillera à donner véritablement les clés
de leur avenir professionnel aux élèves
comme le président je regrette de ne pas
avoir eu de réponse sur le réalisme de
la refonte de tous les manuels scolaires
en même temps sous une petite année les
éditeurs disent que c'est simplement pas
réaliste sans compter la question du
coût bien sûr il faut changer notre
culture par rapport à l'an pro tissage
madame la ministre mais pourquoi est on
à ce moment-là revenu il ya un an la loi
de refondation de l'école sur les
dispositifs dima qui favorise l
apprentissage
voilà on prend les choses complètement à
l'envers il ya des allers retours des
atermoiements
tout ça est très préjudiciable à la
refonte en effet dû du collège le
collège
unique c'est pas le collège uniforme
nous sommes extrêmement attachés à ce
que chaque enfant à partir du socle
commun trouve son parcours de réussite
puissent se voir offrir une orientation
qui correspondent à la fois ses
aptitudes et puis à ses appétences et en
cela nous ne voyons pas en quoi
l'actuelle réforme telle qu'elle est
proposée pour a facilité les choses
enfin je terminerai en disant que jamais
dans le texte de loi proprement dit le
mot réforme des collèges n'a été écrit
prononcer nous sommes posé beaucoup de
questions à l'époque sur le statut de ce
rapport annexé au texte de loi
souvenez vous chers collègues un texte
très verts vont conclure
elles ont donc voilà donc vous
comprendrez pourquoi la surprise elle
est légitime la cerise du parlement mais
aussi la communauté éducative
la parole est à madame catherine
tremblay je demande à chacun de
respecter son temps c'est aussi un
apprentissage le maîtriser le temps
madame tremblay vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues
nombreux furent les personnalités de
tous bords à vous alerter madame la
ministre sur les difficultés que soulève
la réforme du collège celle des
programmes scolaires
il y à une levée de boucliers contre la
suppression du latin du grec contre l'
annonce qu'en 5ème l'enseignement des
lumières deviendra facultatif en
histoire tout comme le christianisme
médiéval qui deviendra une option parmi
d'autres et encore contre la disparition
des classes bilangues et européennes qui
menacera c'est certain demain
l'apprentissage de la langue allemande
les groupes d'amitié france allemagne du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale sont
intervenus contre la suppression des
classes bilangues et européennes
j'ai moi même pris l'initiative d'une
tribune en ce sens qui a été cosigné par
plus de 50 de mes collègues sénateurs il
y a eu encore l'appel de 250
parlementaires et les pétitions
demandant la suppression de la réforme
signé par des dizaines de milliers de
personnes
malgré cela rien n'y fait vous avez
refusé de revoir votre copie et vous
avez encore fait la sourde oreille en
refusant de comprendre que la majorité
des français opposés à votre réforme la
semaine dernière ce sont les
ainsi qu'aux acteurs de l'éducation
nationale le personnel enseignant qui
s'est massivement mobilisée en
manifestant à son tour contre cette
réforme leur voix fait écho aux
inquiétudes de l'association des
professeurs d'histoire-géographie à
celle des professeurs de lettres mais
aussi à celle et professeur d'arts
plastiques ou encore celle des
professeurs de langues vivantes
tous se mobilisent contre cette réforme
qui comme il le rappelle se soldera par
la perte d'heures d'enseignement
disciplinaire au moment les élèves en
ont le plus grand besoin
malgré cela vous avez décidé de passer
en force à france suprême à tous ceux
qui expriment leur profonde inquiétude
de vos réformes votre question avait
publié en catimini au lendemain d'une
grève nationale de décret ainsi que
l'arrêté portant sur la réforme au
journal officiel pour refuser tout
dialogue dans une société en crise voici
ma question est une école en perte de
repères alors qu'une réelle crise de
confiance s'installe entre les français
et leur école entendez vous madame la
ministre
enfin ouvrir une réelle et large
concertation sur la réforme du collège
et celle des programmes scolaires je
vous remercie pour vous répondre aux
lettres de madame la ministre
et je lui demande de pratiquer la
contraction de texte qui est inutile
exercice voilà merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice ne m'en
voudra pas mais d'une phrase je voudrais
répondre à madame morin desailly tout de
même en lui explique enfin on lui on lui
explicite en disant mon propos je pense
qu'il ya une différence fondamentale
entre à l'âge du collège décider que tel
enfant ira dans l'apprentissage dans
l'enseignement professionnel d'office et
que tel autre aura droit à un
enseignement plus générale est donc ce
que vous proposez d'une certaine façon
est ce que nous proposons nous à savoir
ouvrir l'ensemble des élèves à
l'ensemble des matières qu'elle soit en
effet intellectuels et des disciplines
qu'elle soit intellectuel manuel que
l'on puisse y construire son orientation
professionnelle en s'ouvrant toutes les
perspectives possibles mais c'est juste
pour être clair là dessus donc j'insiste
sur ce point parce que je pense qu'il
faut bien préparer les enfants à
l'orientation professionnelle
je reviens à vous pardon madame
la sénatrice trendel bon d'abord je
pense qu'il faut à nouveau quelqu'un a
demandé de la sérénité donc sérénité à
nouveau bien distinguer réforme du
collège réforme des programmes la
réforme des programmes c'est un sujet
vraiment lourd qui n'en est qu'à ses
débuts puisque c'est une instance
indépendante le conseil supérieur des
programmes d'ailleurs dans lequel
siègent des élus de gauche et de droite
qui a fait des projets de programmes sur
toutes les matières de l'école primaire
et du collège travail considérable et je
les remercie qui nous ont été proposés
qui pour l'instant sont soumis à
consultation de 800 mille enseignants
pendant un mois
et c'est seulement au retour de ces
enseignants que nous validerons la
version définitive et je veux insister
sur le fait que moi je suis très à
l'écouté
personne ne se considèrent omniscient en
la matière vous imaginez bien le nombre
de disciplines différentes concernés et
puis le nombre de niveaux
d'apprentissage donc j'ai demandé à ce
qu'on ouvre largement la consultation au
delà des enseignants par exemple
s'agissant du programme d'histoire à de
grands historiens qui seront invités
dans un forum que nous organisons le 3
juin prochain pour apporter leur
éclairage et puis nous aider aussi à
dire comment est ce que l'histoire faux
conduisant sa singularité doit être
enseignée aux enfants en fonction de
leur âge
donc je crois qu'il faut en la matière
vraiment faire preuve de l'esprit
d'apaisement chercher à avoir les
programmes les plus clairs les plus
progressifs les plus efficaces pour que
surtout les enfants les acquiert c'est
ce qui nous intéresse
madame catherine tromelin pour répondre
à la mise
oui merci madame la ministre de votre
réponse en fait je parlais de
concertation à la fois de la réforme du
collège mais également des programmes
les deux chansons liées madame la
ministre vous ne pouvez pas les séparer
un moment des faits sont liés à partir
du moment où les enseignants ont
largement manifesté leur mécontentement
et leur rejet de la réforme du collège
comment voulez vous parler d'une
concertation qui soit sereine sur les
programmes
vous n'avez pas entendu une première
fois comment voulez vous que vous nous
parler aujourd'hui de sérénité voilà
j'en arrête là par rapport à ma réponse
ma chère collègue la parole et à notre
collègue
christian manable pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole pour deux
minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre au moment où certains
s'interrogent sur le débat la réflexion
et la concertation qui entoure la
réforme du collège et on vient encore de
l'entendre sur les bancs de droite de
notre assemblée
il me paraît opportun de rappeler toute
l'ambition et la portée de la loi de
refondation de l'école qui a été porté
initialement par vincent peillon
en effet dans le rapport annexé à la loi
promulguée en 2013 et qui vise à
présenter l'ensemble des orientations et
les chantiers engagés au service de la
réussite de ce grand dessein éducatif
les objectifs fixés par nation sont très
claires je les rappelle ici une école à
la fois juste pour tous et exigeantes
pour chacun la refondation de l'école
doit en priorité permettre une élévation
générale du niveau de tous les élèves et
l'ensemble des composantes du système
éducatif
le premier comme le second degré entre
autres doivent se mobiliser pour la
réalisation de ses objectifs
ainsi jean paul ii l'a est l'un des
contributeurs de cette loi écrivait
encore tout récemment la refondation je
le cite concerne bien sûr tous les
élèves et il n'est pas question de
réduire les écarts en baissant le niveau
des meilleurs refonder l'école ce n'est
pas niveler par le bas c'est élever le
niveau de tous
en centrant l'attention du système
éducatif en priorité en priorité en
direction des plus fragiles ceux dont
les dessins scolaires sont liées à leurs
origines sociales
fin de citation alors madame la ministre
voici ma question je souhaiterais donc
que vous puissiez préciser la place du
collège dans la démarche de refondation
de l'école et mettre ainsi en
perspective la réforme qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui
d'autre part pour illustrer cette
nécessité d'agir sur l'ensemble du
continuum éducatif
je souhaiterais également madame la
ministre vous interroger sur l'un des
engagements de la loi de refondation
avec le développement des compétences
numériques et sa traduction sa
traduction dans la réforme du collège
en effet le collège doit être en phase
avec les usages du numérique
d'aujourd'hui est à prendre en collège
qui s'en servent par ailleurs
quotidiennement et bien à les utiliser à
les maîtriser et à les comprendre alors
qu'elle est c'est la deuxième question
le rôle des collectivités territoriales
dans ce service public du numérique
éducatif et pouvez vous madame la
ministre
oui monsieur le président mais vous êtes
un républicains soucieux d'égalité donc
attendez deux jours mais donc comme mes
prédécesseurs je demande à disposer du
même temps de dépassement pouvez vous
nous préciser les mesures et engagements
dans ces domaines qui s'inscrivent dans
la réforme du collège et le plan
numérique annoncé par le président de la
république il ya quelques semaines mais
bon à la minute mais vous avez consommé
votre temps de réponse après quoi la
ministre
merci pour cette question et merci
d'avoir fait allusion à d'avoir fait
allusion aux à l'excellent rapport de
jean paul ii l'a est en effet qui a eu
cette vertu de remettre peut-être un peu
plus dans le paysage public c'est plus
d'un million d'enfants pauvres qui
fréquentent nos écoles nos collèges et
nos lycées et dont on parle rarement la
difficulté qu'ils éprouvent au quotidien
parfois à s'alimenter à s'habiller à se
concentrer sur leurs devoirs
la façon dont ils en viennent à
décrocher très vite parce qu'ils ont des
familles qui elles mêmes malheureusement
sont dans une instabilité économique qui
ne leur permet pas de suivre les progrès
de leurs enfants et ce rapport était
essentiel pour rappeler aussi pourquoi
la refondation de l'école est faite elle
est faite pour s'intéresser aussi à ces
enfants là pour faire en sorte que parmi
eux
eh bien nous veillons d'abord à lutter
contre l'autocensure parce que c'est
aussi ça qui les guettent ne plus croire
la réussite possible pour eux et puis
que nous soyons toujours à leurs côtés
pour développer le meilleur et j'en
profite pour répondre parce que c'est
vrai que tout à l'heure je n'ai pas été
complète
non le latin et le grec ne sont pas
supprimés dans la réforme du collège le
latin et le grec sont offerts à tous les
collégiens là où jusqu'à présent il ne
bénéficiait qu'à 18 % d'entre eux
pourquoi certains collégiens
parce que ils ne connaissent pas les
codes parce que les familles ne sont pas
informées parce que ils n'ont peut-être
pas en place de sixième quand ils
arrivent au collège les meilleurs fois
reformant scolaire
possible pourquoi est ce que on
offrirait pas à ces collégiens la
possibilité de s'élever parlant
d'élévation du niveau comme de
l'intellect par la pratique et par
l'enseignement du latin et du grec c'est
précisément ce qu'offre cette réforme du
collège
mais cette réforme du collège est la
vocation aussi à moderniser nos
enseignements et c'est vrai que
l'utilisation du numérique est un
formidable potentiel une formidable
opportunité s'est passé un peu inaperçu
mais le président dans le public il ya
dix jours annoncé un plan d'un milliard
d'euros faucoucourt d'euros sur trois
ans pour permettre d'équiper tous les
collèges à la fois équipements j'allais
dire numérique remonter dans les outils
pour que les élèves les utilisent mais
aussi de former les enseignants et
permettre aux élèves à la fois de
connaître les outils de les utiliser et
d'apprendre la civilité numérique qui
est un sujet à enjeu vous le savez
autant que moi monsieur je presque deux
mots merci madame la ministre
mes collègues ont soufflé la réponse
cette réponse d'une ancienne amie et de
wazin actuelle aviez dois me convient
parfaitement
mais au-delà de ce dénominateur commun
géographique
je voudrais quand même insisté sur
l'apport à non là vraiment rupture sur
la question du numérique en un mot car
pour rester parfaitement connecté il
faut des tuyaux la décision qui a été
prise par le président de la république
par le gouvernement va dans le bon sens
mais je voudrais insister sur le fait
que l'intervention publique reste
indispensable en zone rurale où les
opérateurs privés nous le savons
rechignent à investir
merci monsieur le président cette étude
horloge picarde la parole est maintenant
à monsieur jacques grosperrin pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
on devait la parole merci président
madame la ministre
messieurs et mesdames les sénateurs la
réforme du collège que vous avez menées
avec brutalité dogmatisme à dresser
contre le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez les acteurs de la communauté
éducative
l'opinion publique est de nouveaux
intellectuels des vrais intellectuels
comment en êtes vous arrivé là vous
partiez cependant du bon attention si
l'on en croit vos déclarations ne
s'agissait disiez vous de partir de ce
qui marche déjà sur le terrain délibéré
les capacités d'initiative
je vous donne acte de la mise en oeuvre
d'un attention de la libération des
initiatives l'accroissement d'ailleurs
de l'autonomie va dans le bon sens mais
pour le reste
quel échec vous prétendez en effet
partir de ce qui marche sur le terrain
et vous commencez par supprimer les
expériences pédagogiques qui ont fait la
preuve de leur efficacité leur
attractivité
je parlais des classes bilangues et
l'enseignement des langues anciennes en
tant que matière à part entière sur les
classes bilangues vous supprimez
propositions pédagogiques qui permet
l'apprentissage de deux langues dès la
6è et qui concerne actuellement 80 mille
élèves de 6e et qui a permis à partir de
2005 de maintenir les effectifs en
allemand en remplacement de cette
proposition qui fonctionne sur le
terrain vous proposez que tous les
élèves puissent apprendre une deuxième
langue de leur choix dès la 5e
cette modification pose trois problèmes
d'abord comme l'a relevé
monsieur ayrault il y à fort à craindre
que les élèves fassent le choix de
l'allemand contre l'espagnol ensuite nos
élèves n'auront pas le niveau suffisant
pour appréhender
une deuxième langue dès la 5e et voulait
conduire et à l'échec
enfin nombreuses familles vont fuir le
collège public pour aller dans les
établissements privés qui eux
proposeront des classes bilangues sur
les langues anciennes
vous prétendez leur offrir à tous alors
que voulait supprimer un tank
anciennement autonome qui peut croire
que les mesures de votre réformes
permettront de les sauvegarder
en réalité votre fête tous les éleveurs
le bac est une fois de plus combien le
socialisme un problème avec l'excellence
est l'amérique progressé
ma question ne serait-il pas encore
temps madame la ministre de retirer ce
texte pour travailler en véritable
concertation avec les acteurs pour faire
en sorte que les enfants de la
république réussissent et enfin à quel
moment le parlement a dit il se
prononcer sur le contenu de cette
réforme du collège qui d'après vous fait
suite à la loi de réparation dès l'école
minute quand même la ministre pour
répondre je suis certain que monsieur
grosperrin contractera sion tourner
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le sénateur grosperrin à quel moment est
ce que les parlementaires se sont
prononcés lors de l'adoption de la loi
de refondation en 2013 c'était il y à 22
mois que comporte cette réforme du
collège s'agissant des langues vivantes
puisque vous avez évoqué les langues
vivantes étrangères
elle prévoit que l'apprentissage de la
langue vivante 2 se fasse de façon plus
précoce qu'actuellement puisque
actuellement les enfants attendent la
classe de 4e pour commencer leur
deuxième langue vivante
demain il l'a commenceront dès la classe
de 5e
toutes les enquêtes démontrent que une
exposition plus précoce à une langue
vivante étrangère en renforcent la
maîtrise et que salah va dans l'intérêt
évident de tous ces jeunes qui seront
amenés sans doute à rejoindre le marché
du travail dans les années 2000 23 que
de pratiquer de façon aisée de langue
vivante étrangère quelle que soit
d'ailleurs les métiers qui seront les
leurs les classes bilangues que vous
évoquez
en réalité la logique des classes
bilangues qui consistait donc à faire
pratiquer deux langues vivantes
étrangères dès la classe de sixième mais
pour une minorité de collégiens 15%
avait cette possibilité
la logique est non seulement préservé
mais étendue à tous les collégiens
puisque vous êtes d'accord avec moi le
bilinguisme sera désormais offert à tous
les collégiens en classe de cinquième en
revanche j'insiste à nouveau sur un
point c'est que ce qu'il demeurera dans
la réforme du collège c'est la
possibilité cette fois ci garantit à
tous les élèves et pas seulement dans
les collèges qui on avait envie à tous
les élèves qui auront commencé en langue
vivante une à l'école primaire une autre
langue que l'anglais de pouvoir accéder
à l'anglais langue vivante 2 dès la
classe de sixième
pourquoi est ce que nous faisons en
conclut que nous savons que ce qui peut
arrêter les parents dans le choix d'une
langue vivante une autre que l'anglais
c'est la crainte que leurs enfants
d'abord de l'anglais langue
indispensable de notre monde que trop
tard en classe de quatrième et bien
aujourd'hui ce que nous leur proposons
s'il faut conclure prennent une autre
langue en élever une la lv2 anglais sera
elle accessible dès la classe de 6e
c'est une formidable façon de
diversifier le choix des langues c'est
dû en effet pur ou dégoûtés par classe
grosperrin pour conclure puisque oui
très rapidement je suis garant de
l'équité ici merci président madame la
ministre vous savez très bien et les
associations parents d'élèves nous l'ont
dit avant-hier que dans la loi de
refondation de l'école il n'a pas été
question du collège donc vous avez
confisquer la parole au parlement
il faut le dire soit c'est un
rétropédalage on l'a bien compris soit
vous êtes rendu compte que il fallait
passer en force
soit vous faites la concertation à ce
moment là il fallait en discuter dans le
parlement
parce que travailler sur fond de décret
ce n'est pas honorable vis-à-vis en tout
cas ne lisent la république et deuxième
chose
ce rétropédalage on l'a très bien senti
parce qu' il fallait passer en force
vous sentiez que quelque part les
acteurs de la vie éducative allait agir
dans ce sens là et enfin je crois qu'il
aurait été plus judicieux de travailler
sur les formes d'exploitation dans
certains départements si vous voulez
véritablement cette forme de travail et
de réforme du collège merci mon cher
collègue la parole est aux mains
d'hommes joëlle garriaud-maylam pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues les
français sont mondialement réputés pour
leur piètre maîtrise des langues
étrangères
une sous-performance bien sûr lié à
notre système d'apprentissage des
langues à l'école et au collège pas de
miracle deux ou trois heures de cours
par semaine ne suffisent pas à devenir
bilingues
la plupart des postes à responsabilités
y compris en france exige aujourd'hui un
véritable plurilinguisme les classes
villelongue européennes et
internationales permettent de l'acte
indre en plus un volume en horaires
renforcés en langue elle favorise
l'enseignement en langue étrangère des
disciplines non linguistiques un
enseignement pluridisciplinaire ludique
ne parviendra jamais au même objectif
ces classes sont dit il it is mais quel
mal y at-il à permettre aux élèves qui
le peuvent de maîtriser réellement des
langues étrangères tandis que ceux en
difficultés dans l'acquisition d'un
socle fondamental en écriture on lecture
serez aidé en petits groupes pour coup à
contraindre l'ensemble des élèves à
s'initier dès la cinquième à deux
langues étrangères alors que certains ne
maîtrise pas les fondamentaux et
pourrait développer sur ce créneau
horaire des talents non linguistique un
vernis de lv2 est il utile à la réussite
professionnelle
la bi langues pour tous dès la cinquième
est un mensonge
le collège unique avait la preuve de son
échec pourquoi s'enfoncer encore dans la
même mauvaise direction généralisant le
saupoudrage en langue vivante et
ancienne plus que de ludique les élèves
ont besoin de repères
le collège doit leur donner les bases
leur future réussite
n'oublions pas la dimension diplomatique
des classes bilangues européenne leur
suppression est très mal perçue
outre-rhin
il est à craindre que par le jeu de la
réciprocité l'enseignement du français
en allemagne en pâtissent durement
l'enjeu est aussi celui de
l'attractivité internationale de notre
question éducatif femmes la renommée des
lycées français à l'étranger est fondée
sur celle de l'éducation à la française
remettre en cause ce modèle c'est
affaiblir nos établissements dans un
contexte de vive concurrence
internationale
je m'interroge aussi sur la mise en
oeuvre pratique
réforme ma question sachant que 400
millions d'euros seraient nécessaires
pour accompagner les nouveaux programmes
pourquoi votre ministère halte il
inscrit seulement 60 millions d'euros
dans son budget triennal qui pâtira des
arbitrages budgétaires pour éviter
qu'une génération de collégiens ne soit
sacrifiée sur l'autel d'une réforme
précipitée
pourquoi ne pêchent le nez son entrée en
vigueur le 12 3
madame la ministre pour répondre
brièvement pour que ce soit
compréhensible parce que je vois que
alesi la classe était la discipline
aujourd'hui allez-y oui madame la
sénatrice garriaud-maylam bon d'abord
pardonnez-moi mais dans votre propos il
y a quelque chose que je ne peux pas
admettre contre quoi je m'élève lorsque
vous dites demain les postes à
responsabilités recueilleront une bonne
maîtrise des langues étrangères et c'est
pour cela que nous devons former une
élite à maîtriser ces langues étrangères
mais non je crois que tous les postes à
responsabilités comme pas responsabilité
recueilleront une maîtrise des langues
étrangères et c'est pour cela qu'il faut
veiller à l'offrir à tout le monde c'est
bien le sujet c'est quelle métier
prépare tant pour 2023
à nouveau je le dis ici je ne crois pas
à des métiers qui serait faiblement
qualifiés en 2023 je crois que ça
n'existe pas et donc sous payé
d'ailleurs je crois que ça n'existe pas
le siècle que qui est le nôtre exige que
nous ayons un niveau de qualification
élevé pour l'ensemble de la population
et c'est ce que fait cette réforme du
collège se poursuivent en vous disant
que vous semblez croire que la réforme
du collège va imposer exactement le même
fonctionnement à tous les établissements
une forme d'uniformité que vous rejetez
mais je vous comprends moi aussi je suis
contre l'uniformité et je rappelle que
s'il y a 20 % d'autonomie dans les
collèges à partir de 2016 c'est
précisément pour que eux qui sont les
mieux placés décident s'ils consacrent
davantage de temps à de l'accompagnement
personnalisé comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure au quotidien des enfants plus en
difficulté ils vont en faire plus ou
alors faire davantage d'enseignements
pratique interdisciplinaire par exemple
en langue vivante étrangère donc s'il
souhaite faire davantage de langues
vivantes ils peuvent le faire ch
que sert l'autonomie je terminerai
simplement par deux mots le premier
c'est que oui la loi de refondation de
l'école et les débats qui ont entouré a
bien abordé la réforme du collège cessé
de dire le contraire
il suffit de la relire pour y voir
réaffirmation du collège unique
enseignements complémentaires autonomie
des établissements pratiquent diverses y
vaut donc lui rebonds et dernier mot les
manuels scolaires puisque vous nous
interroger sur ce point les manuels
scolaires évidemment seront prêts en
temps utile pour entrer en vigueur pour
la réforme en 2016 et c'était important
d'avoir à la fois une organisation du
collège échanges ainsi que ces pratiques
mais j'ai loupé les honoraires de jouer
chacun pour soi et des manuels en
cohérence aux dix secondes
guillaume lemans d'une part vous n'avez
pas répondu sur la question du coût
madame la ministre
deuxièmement vous avez 15 % des
collégiens aujourd'hui qui sont dans des
classes bilangues il aurait fallu
augmenter ce nombre ça sort était
important aujourd'hui que se passe-t-il
madame la ministre nous n'avons même pas
suffisamment d'enseignants en langues
nous n'avons pas les moyens de former
nous savons que nous n'avons pas été
capables de remplir les poches 100 capes
d'allemand alors de quoi ce nouveau nom
s'y imposer des cours de l'homme par des
enseignants qui ne connaissent pas ces
plantes qui n'ont pas la capacité ce
sera un échec
voilà pour ces questions cribles
consacré à la réforme du collège
on reste sur cette même thématique
puisque je vous propose après viseront
devoir l'audition de najat vallaud
belkacem du mois de juin lorsqu'elle
avait été auditionné par la commission
d' enquête sur le service public de
l'éducation
cette commission d'enquêté sénatoriale a
été créé à la demande du groupe ex ump
les républicains aujourd'hui au
lendemain des attentats de janvier elle
avait pour objectif est bien d'analyser
la perte de repères républicain dans la
vie scolaire également de voir à quelles
difficultés certains professeurs sont
confrontés dans l'exercice de leur
profession tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition